all right Justin yes Justin uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally
I'm from Northern California I grew up
in San Ramon my entire life I was raised
with my grandparents
um when I was a young child a young
infant my mother was uh psychiatrically
uh unstable she had some sort of mental
breakdown and she was unable to care for
my sister and I so she was in a mental
hospital and unable to uh basically we
were going to go to foster care and my
grandparents took us in
um where was your dad my dad he was
never part of my life I've actually
never met him and
he he's been in prison my entire life he
committed a murder when I was four years
old
and he pretty much just um
was um
I would say he
use my mom just to have children and
then just left her and found a new a new
female and he ended up killing a new
female
um when he moved to Missouri and uh I
didn't find out about any of this we
didn't even know we had a father figure
in our lives up up until we were like
around 12 years old because my grandpa
was that was that figure in my life so
until we got old enough to realize you
know the age difference in mom and dads
at school and our grandparents you know
we were told the truth so uh it was kind
of like a secret my grandparents kept
um it really did affect me though not
having a dad because
seeing everyone else at school you know
with um having their their fathers uh
and their mom and and everyone uh
whether they're just being you know a
part of their lives um with sports or
whatever you know I didn't really have
that
um it in the abandonment with with my
mom was pretty much
um my number one thing as far as my dad
I don't really know him he's kind of a
ghost I've never met him except spoke
I've spoken to him on the phone
um
probably a good five to ten times uh
growing up he did try to be a part of
our Lives of being in prison when we
found out and tried to establish
relationship
um but he just
he just ghosted us as as far as when he
got out of prison
um never met him or anything we don't
even
associate with him to this day
um you know I'm 25 years old and I've
tried to
reach out to him in the past five five
years or so and uh whether it's Facebook
or or a message or trying to call he
just ignores me I've never met any part
of his his type of uh side of the family
so there I don't know any of the
um the Missouri residents he he grew up
in Missouri uh he's never been in
California or made an effort and to be
honest I don't even feel like I have a
father
um you know my grandpa kind of took that
place as a young age and I've kept it
like that how would you describe your
childhood my childhood was
um
I would say it was really
um mild and uh and and very um
it was really stable
um my grandpa and grandma made sure my
sister and I had everything we needed as
far as you know
um the necessary like uh stuff for
school and sports and music yeah I'm
afraid you go in school I went to up to
my general Ed in Diablo Valley Community
College oh so you graduated high school
um I went to California high school and
I graduated in 2016.
um what have you done since you finished
school
um so this is kind of where I went
downhill
um
so my travels Okay so
at around 16 years old I started using a
little bit of substances and I ran away
with you know a girl and whatnot and uh
I tried to
reunite with my mom and stuff and she
was like my best friend at one point
because I have some abandonment issues
from where she left us when we were we
were young she never was really like in
our lives and stuff but um as far as um
two okay so when I was 18 my mom was
murdered and that is what really
affected me to my choices to where I
haven't completed in the last seven
years I haven't completed much
um I've been in a cycle of rehab
jails
and
overdoses
um I've distorted a ton of relationships
whether that's former friends family
members nobody wants to deal with me
because of my drug addiction problem and
my
I know I have a lot of underlying trauma
and depression that is undealt with
um to be honest it's it's really stems
from my mom's murder um
I don't know what I don't know how to
explain it but I was living with her
trying to repair our relationships when
I was uh 17 18 years old
and I didn't like how she was using
substances so when I came back to
California
um
to work I worked at UPS and and I was
you know uh five months after I left her
she was she was killed so
I have some sort of guilt for leaving
her uh in Arizona alone in the trailer
park
um
I have a lot of uh family issues with
my grandparents as well because they
left her property all to be disposed of
her mobile home her two cars
um her two storage units every I don't
even have a picture of her
um as far as like something that's like
a Memento or any type of sentimental
thing
and my mom was always there for me as
far as when I was like growing up she
wanted to repair the damage and of not
being there raising us
she has some she yes she was my number
one writer always there
um up until
like I was when I was a teenager at
least you know she really wanted to be
there
um
when I was younger you know growing up
from my Early Childhood as a uh as a kid
going into teenagers she wasn't there
she was with a uh abusive husband of
hers named Terry and he was a a like a
steroid user and my mom actually had a
son with him and I kind of took the
place of she just she was raising my
little brother with and me and my twin
sister uh Michaela were kind of pushed
aside
but me being uh
kind of like a mama's boy and wanted to
be
um a part of her life and having her um
I want see I have her tattooed right
here and she really was a big part of my
life um
losing her really affected everything in
my life how old were you when she passed
away I was 18 years old she passed away
uh January 12 2016.
and uh What Hurts the Most is I was
really building a good relationship with
her in the past couple years of her you
know over of her life before she died
um
it really it really devastated me
because
that was the only person I could tell
any secret to not be judged and and
always always be there no matter what
whether I had warrants running away
whether and send me sending me money she
will always keep me safe and losing her
was
I stopped caring about everything I I
literally started committing crimes
after after that how was she murdered I
quit my job and everything she was
murdered um
so the story I have a theory on the
story
um there is some some news on Google
that is totally wrong
um
she was taking care of a guy named Wade
chocolate she had a big tumor on his
neck
um it's like a size of a golf ball his
uh he I'm pretty sure I know what she
was doing she was caregiving for him
until he dies to probably try to take
his house I know I know her and I'm
pretty sure uh the guy found out that
she was gonna take his house when he
died so he killed her instead
um third story is so he shot her twice
in the chest with a rifle said it was an
accident
um which obviously that's that's
[__]
um she had methamphetamine in her system
so there's really no telling of what
really stand what went wrong but I know
that for a fact my mom was a manipulator
and wanted that guy's house I just know
I have a feeling and if he found out he
obviously I'm pretty sure he killed
killed every
um because
I don't I don't know but I'm pretty sure
that was the reason and
it was pretty sad because uh they
covered her up in a
with a blanket left her dead for two
days on the ground in a flat Canyon City
Arizona on in the desert
um it was like a Trailer Park area with
like mobile homes that are stationary
and a lot of trailer trash guys with
drug problems and Felons and whatnot
that would um
you know steal property or whatever they
stole her two cars the mobile home and
and I literally had to go on Facebook
and call the sheriff to get the mobile
home towed because a guy named Randy
Johnson uh
made a fake bill of sale when she died
and said that she she gave it to him and
I had to get it towed because it was it
was like it bothered me a lot that he
could just do that and take take the
last property that she had because I was
gonna go go to us you know on the mo and
I I'm just like
and just devastated with
have drugs been a part of your life yeah
sadly my
um
out of uh all my family members I'm the
one who has the most substance uh drug
problem that has been pretty much
unfixable I've been to about 20 rehabs
and about 10 different detox programs
every time I've you know I've tried to
get clean I cannot sustain longer than
four months when did this start for you
I started around 16 years old using
marijuana
and
it didn't really progress much until I
was around 17 18 I you know I started
drinking and uh after the marijuana the
drinking weren't really like
you know
um
I I experimented a lot in high school
you know things changed uh when I went
to college I used a lot of pills and I
had started on pills I actually have a
chronic pain condition in my left hip
called legs Perthes and um I used a
coating at first then I went to the
Norcos
soon enough it was heroin and Fentanyl
and uh to this day
I've I'm having trouble with um pretty
much any substance that is uh
is mind altering I will use I will find
a way
um and my last uh my last substance that
was a big problem was Fentanyl
um I I you know I
I was introduced to it in 2021
um by a girl in rehab that I met
and
ever since that time until now I've been
pretty much on and off of it fighting it
with the uh using Suboxone to try to to
manage the cravings and addiction and
stuff but
I have uh
pretty much given up you know I I get
sober and then I give up and I don't
understand why I just cannot have that
uh enough willpower too
so
well I know kind of why I'm using a lot
of time is I don't have stable housing
ever I've been rejected and abandoned my
whole life
um I've had it since a child when was my
mom not being there raising us with my
grandparents kicking me out at a young
age 16 years old letting me back in
kicking me out again it was it's been a
long uh cycle of being
kind of like uh kicked out and you know
I had a little bit of anger problems
with my alcohol uh issues I was
alcoholic before before I used opiates
you know which doesn't make sense how I
switched to a different to that type of
drug from alcohol but um
in 2020 in 2019 I was I got three DUIs
and I flipped the car I had a lot of
recklessness it's really been a a crazy
life for me because I've had so many
near-death experiences
um and then every time something that is
super
dangerous that happens to me or an
overdose or
I get
assaulted or left or dead or I just
always um
you know I just
somebody's looking out for me
and uh by the grace of God I just keep
getting all these chances
where are you staying now
um
to be honest I don't really have a place
to stay
um I came came in from
foreign
bus from San Francisco
down here to L.A
sorry and um
yeah my grandparents just sent me down
here
kind of just gave me tough love and
it cut me off again
they said you're gonna go to rehab or
you're not gonna you know be part of our
life anymore and they keep doing this
and they're like my only family they
raised me like my mom and dad is is the
place they have in my life this is who
they are as far as
just them uh them rejecting me and then
I have a little brother and a twin
sister where they they help out and
they're they're part of their lives but
then they put me to the side they don't
understand what addiction is like
because it's you can't control it you
know my dad was a a dick an alcoholic
and a Xanax abuser my mom was a Pill
Popper and Fentanyl user
um I have those genes no matter what
it's instilled in my brain
you know I use drugs and alcohol to to
know my feelings and my trauma my pain
yeah it's still it's just sad because
they don't people that don't have uh the
addictions they don't understand what
it's like yeah and they struggle with
not having a place to live
of course I'm gonna use drugs if I have
nowhere to go you know like um the
housing has been my biggest problem
firm past like eight nine years I've
been in shelters I've been in so many
rehabs and you know me keep failing at
them um
like
there's just no moving forward from it I
can never get past like even
like a small residential program
um or like uh I just don't have that in
me I just
you know I think I can do it and then
all of a sudden something happens
something triggers me and I just go back
out but I know a lot of it has to do
with my grandparents um
they put it like a restrain going around
me
um and they've done like this power
struggle before they let me back in if
and and then kicked me back out or get
me arrested because because if I don't
do what they they say
you know
it's
it's just like sad to know that I've
been betrayed so many times and and then
I just
I've had a very very uh difficult
upbringing as far as the last few few
years you feel helpless against your
addiction
um let's go yeah fentanyl is really
difficult to it's been the hardest yeah
it really has been the hearts
like I thought my alcoholism was the
hardest when drinking two handles a day
for over a year and a half
drink and drive and everything you know
lose my license what not but
when I hit the fentanyl it's it's been a
part of my life to where I cannot stop
and it's like every 30 minute things you
have to use to feel normal otherwise the
woods are awesome and whatnot and
I'm not gonna lie a lot of times these
but no I just don't want to wake up
sometimes I wouldn't say it I'm
necessarily suicidal or anything but
having no family support
or understanding what I go through
and they're living on the streets
only 25 years old like I used to have a
pretty pretty good job
you know shot a good pretty good chance
at um you know going to college and
continuing my baseball aspirations and
whatnot and uh I threw everything away
my my mom was killed I just gave up I
literally had a broken heart still do I
haven't gone to counseling or grieved or
anything from it but I just gave up I
started
getting in trouble
and uh ever since I've been on probation
for eight years I cannot get off of it
no matter what I just keep going it's
one after another one is petty crimes or
I don't you know I have no violent
crimes it's all drug or alcohol related
everything I do
uh
I've been very Reckless but I have tried
I really have tried I it's gonna be so
frustrating to go through this and yeah
not even your family
kind of abandons you
yeah it's been uh so hard to quit right
it's been almost impossible
um because
I really need like
stable housing and counseling and uh the
right medication and you know the right
people to guide me and I don't have that
and doing it on my own I don't I can't I
can't I've tried so many times last year
in 2021 I thought I had it under my belt
I met a girl in her co-ed rehab we got
silver together for four months and um I
actually got her pregnant and she's
raising my son to this day
um he's 10 months old now his name is
Braxton and even having him and her in
my life last year when I moved to Texas
sober with him when I had a little bit
of clean time I threw it away I went uh
drinking for a whole month and threw it
away and her family said bye you know
they uh so now they hate me they judge
me
um my baby mama
um she's been staying sober and uh
nobody can understand why I can't I
can't can't do it
you know um
but you know I was so close to building
something last year and that's my like
where I want to get back to that level
to where I was you know I wouldn't work
for a Texas job for eight dollars an
hour that's what what
um
you know I I wouldn't do I was too
stubborn when I went out there and uh I
couldn't tell her her um
her stepdad that I I could have worked
for him because I have felons or
felonies
um
because he offered me a job when I when
I went out there I threw everything away
um that they offered uh last year I I
had I had a chance and uh
fast forward till now it's been a it's
been
out of control I literally had a my
physical health deteriorate super super
fast
um
not only using the fentanyl I've been
experimenting with crystal meth as well
and that's just been [__] bad uh
I've lost a couple teeth and and you
know and
damaged uh
I don't even know what how much damage
I've done I've fallen a lot I've taken a
lot of Xanax uh my memory is bad uh it's
pretty poor as far as the short term and
a lot of blackouts
um I've been
really out of control
um
and you know
there's this like Angel or somebody
washed it out for me keeping me a lot
but
uh you know it's not going to happen
forever something you know
it's like a few months ago when I was in
my grandma's house and it was in April
I uh overdosed and she came down at two
in the morning and saw me blue in her
kitchen
and you know she saved my life uh you
know they called the the cops and stuff
but they Narcan me and um it took four
narkins to get me back
but uh I uh
I didn't want to be woken up to be
honest at that point because my life has
been so miserable and I'm like at the
point where I need to do something to to
make myself
happy I mean I haven't felt happy in
except that little time last year with
my girl with with Bridget
um
I have her tattooed right here she was a
big part of my life she was the key to
my heart you know she has my son and I
haven't even been a part of it he's
almost one years old
I'm never
really try to do much I haven't sent any
money I haven't uh
you know done the anything to stay sober
and this is what they want you know
I miss the birth of my child my first
son
so it's like
as far as anyone who sees the way I
behave like they think I don't care
and it's not just necessarily I don't
care it's I I don't have that love for
myself like I you know
and
all and all the rejection put Downs that
I get from people and family and the
street life just adds up
sets up to where you can't you can't
sustain a normal life I can't get a job
if I'm on the street like living in a
tent or or you know I even try to get in
a gym membership
if I can't sleep there you know and all
the time I'm you know I stay outside I
just lose all my stuff people just take
it off you know and the fence always
been a big contributing fact that I lost
my engagement ring you know passing out
and just fall asleep and everything's
gone this last time in LA I had a
suitcase came down here with 200 uh last
month intentions I'm going to rehab
to stop using the Fentanyl and get back
on Suboxone and whatnot I wanted to and
I literally I lost my suitcase I lost my
backpack I lost my phone
and now I'm here I'm here in La stuck
um
you know stealing from stores to survive
and to be honest this is how it is I I
don't know
how I'm gonna be able to keep myself
you know hygienically clean without
having any resources to to use from
um there's not much to be honest out
there there's there's no um I'm 25 and
there's no like uh young man program or
silver uh that's what I'm disappointed
with the state California they don't
have anything that will uh put people
like me that are struggling kicked out
or in this you know in and out of the
system
um into some sort of stable housing
rehab is not always always what we drug
addicts need
um we need we need love and and count
like real counseling not just to be
labeled
I know
I just do you find yourself losing hope
sometimes I feel like I'm on a very thin
uh
thin rope that has deteriorated to like
dental floss and I'm very close to
Breaking that and once that breaks it's
all gone I the Hope's gone I'm very
close like I've I'm not going to say
I've been suicidal but I've had thoughts
of not wanting to be
here on Earth because it's it's it's
miserable miserable
foreign
you know I got a twin sister who's doing
really well in nursing school she's got
no drug problems you know I got a little
brother's
UC Riverside playing baseball doing what
I wanted to do
you know
he used to look up to me
now he just hates me he despises me my
sister won't even talk to me she's in
Ventura I won't even come drop me off
the clothes
or like a meal
but it is what it is I'm a grown man now
I have to I have to be a [__] man you
feel like people don't understand how
difficult it is they don't know what
it's like and there never will if they
don't educate themselves and actually
listen
I'm not using to just uh
get high I'm using to numb my feelings
into my pain and to stop feeling one of
I don't want to feel the way I feel
um and deal with life how it is because
it's it's horrible being on a street
broke all the time with
having to hustle for the next fix and
then uh
starving and it's just like it's just
it's just it's horrible you know I've
had a lot of bad experiences whether
it's like being assaulted being robbed
being left for dead
uh
this last experience I thought was going
to be a turning point for me on July
26th I got hit by a car
I got ran down in San Francisco on from
Market Street
um I'm sorry I'm gonna try and push for
some sort of victim victims compensation
for that but I got
I got ran down and dragged for a half a
mile I have scars on my knees I had my
entire knees Raw uh the from the road
rash and my feet were ran over and then
the second uh the second they tried to
run me over the second time like they
came around the block after hitting me
and what happened was I filled up their
gas tank for like five bucks of gas I
left the door open I had my property on
the floorboard well they closed the door
when I was done filling up gas and then
they tried to take off so I couldn't get
back in the passenger side I was in a
stranger's car I always put myself in
situations like where I'm in strange
cars but uh they took off with my
property and I grabbed onto the the door
try to you know I didn't think you were
gonna take off with me hanging on the
door and uh the person just decided to
drag me in the concrete until I fell off
and the pain was just eventually
unbearable I had to I had to let go and
it was uh pretty bad because I remember
I was helpless laying in the Middle
Street
and I couldn't move
and I had a hole in my ankle bleeding
gushing I just couldn't move and I
thought that was gonna be enough for me
to say I gotta stop doing what I'm doing
but I'm gonna die
but it's not it hasn't been
look where I am now
um
I've been
you know assaulted by uh
people with pistols and and you know Rob
probably a good 40 times I'm not gonna
lie it's been a lot I've lost so much
what's rougher San Francisco or L.A
it's it's really comparable
um you got uh
I got more experience in San Francisco
as far as what I know out there but La
is a lot more dangerous but you're in
the town I was uh yeah I was in general
Lane uh now you're in school Turk and
Taylor Town of Ellis and whatnot yeah I
lived off of Fifth Street at the MSC
shelter
um I try to make some stuff work out
there as far as uh
trying to fix my life like with the
shelter and try to get a job but I
wouldn't work I've been for some reason
I haven't wanted to work because of the
drug problems and whatnot and being lazy
and
I don't know it's just uh ever since
I've been addicted super hot super hard
like I'm talking like a really bad habit
like two to three grams a day which
could amount to you know
60 to 100 depending on where you get it
but
I'm really literally I know it's like
I've been killing myself slowly and uh
San Francisco versus LA as far as danger
goes
it's very close call but I know La is a
lot worse because I've been here such a
short amount of time and I've seen a lot
worse I've already uh experienced the
gunshots near me you know I'm outside
all the time people I've I've been
chased for smoking fentanyl by by
different gangs
um I don't care you know
they're gonna see you know like they're
gonna see me getting high like they
don't own the streets you know just
because uh because then we get high like
you gotta understand I'm I'm Numb
numbing my opinion and you to come
assault me and hurt me for doing
something
that you don't understand why I'm doing
doing the drug in the first place
you don't have any idea like they have
no there's a lot of people that are evil
out here this has been the meanest
experience out here in my entire life
San Francisco there's a lot more nights
for people there's a lot more money out
there I guess is what I was saying
um
I've had a lot of weird calls out here
uh these like
people that are predators try to pick me
up because I'm a young white guy out
here alone you know I'm pretty good
looking and
is what I think and uh
I've had a lot of people try to take me
home and whatnot or or even try to like
drug me and whatnot you know it's been
bad you know it's been bad I've had to
fight for my life several times
Justin what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
you've been through realizing what I've
been through this is in in
it's really
why and am I living like this is you
know I know I don't want to live like
this but I continue to do
and the most important lesson is I'm
gonna die if I don't change
I've literally told my folks you're
gonna have to pick a pick a spot to bury
me
because I don't know how long I'm gonna
last
um and that's just the truth every time
I hit the foil with the fentanyl if I go
back to and
it's like you never know that last one
hit well there's a scale here
you know the other day I saved a guy at
MacArthur Park
he took two hits of Fentanyl and was out
and you got all these other dope fiends
coming up asking to hit the foil while
he's dying
it's just total totally uh
inhumane type of people
you don't care uh we are just
essentially uh
trash out here is what Society views a
lot of us
and
we're humans
you know we're just struggling
for me to learn a lesson about my story
and all the [__] I've gone through
is really to I gotta reflect on
my uh my my
experiences and why I'm living like like
on Reckless
drug addict a junkie
you know I have goals or I used to have
goals but I never put any action to the
plate I always push it to the side
so it's uh do you blame yourself for
this or do you see that maybe you
inherited something from your family I
know it's got to be some sort of
genetics hit because I I never chose
this I never
I had a good high school experience you
know never really using much other than
a little bit of weed you know I know I
[__] up downhill when my when I was my
mom I started using the hardship
I stopped caring and then my dad not
ever wanted to
um be a part of my life and uh the false
promises and
my grandparents kicking me out and this
just adds up
[Music]
to be too hard on yourself
not that you don't need to take
responsibility but
but you have to consider your family too
I don't really feel like I have family
to be honest no but I mean your genetics
oh yeah yeah right
it's just hard because you you know I'm
the one the the black sheep of the
family I'm the one who got the bad genes
the ones that uh I didn't choose to have
this thing it's not all your fault yeah
and then that's how it is that's what
they don't see you know and I wish they
could see that I think they're just
frustrated
they won't even go to it like an AAA
meeting you know it's even open up their
ears
as far as everyone thinks they can just
go to rehab and fix themselves
you know that's what they think and I've
been to 20 30 of them it's not
it would have worked by now
it has to come within here
and within I gotta fix what's up here
all right Justin thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you very much I hope something
great happens for you
thank you God bless you thank you